-The Oscars
are coming up this Sunday,
and it has been a great year
for diversity in film,
and with that in mind,
we have two very special guests
from the American
Diversity Council,
who are here today to honor
the most diverse film of 2018.
Please welcome Linda Porter
and Peter Ralph.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you both so much
for being here.
-It's good to be here, Seth.
-This is very exciting.
Your organization's analysts
have crunched the numbers
and determined the most diverse
movie of last year,
and you're going to announce it
on the show tonight.
-Yeah. Uh, that's
what we're gonna do.
-So, what is it?
"Crazy Rich Asians"?
"Roma"? "Black Panther"?
-Look, Seth, I don't think
you're gonna like
what we have to say.
-Yeah, I think it might be best
to just pull the plug
on this right now.
-Are you kidding me?
No, this is really exciting.
Diversity is very important.
Let's do it.
-Fine. Okay.
[ Breathes deeply ]
Seth, it is with some regret
that we have to announce
that the most diverse movie
of 2018 is
"Backyard Bus Bangers 6."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry. What did you say?
-We at the American
Diversity Council
used a highly scientific rubric
to determine which film released
in the last year was
the most diverse and inclusive.
Unfortunately,
that film turned out to be
"Backyard Bus Bangers 6."
The sixth movie in the
"Backyard Bus Bangers" series.
-I gotta say,
that sounds like a --
-It is pornography, Seth.
But "Backyard Bus Bangers 6,"
I'm sorry to say,
has a more diverse cast than
any other movie made in 2018.
-The movie features
African-American actors,
Hispanic actors, Indian actors,
Chinese actors.
-And there's really no easy way
to put this,
but our study found
that "Backyard Bus Bangers 6"
features roughly nine times
more interracial relationships
than any other movie
made in the last year.
-And when you include Jewish
director Hershel Thrust...
the production
clearly embraced diversity
both in front of
and behind the camera.
-Does certainly sound diverse.
-Also, it's worth noting
that while
Nick Jonas and Priyanka Chopra
are not in this movie,
there is a couple that looks
almost exactly like them.
-Their names are Prick Bonas
and Peeonya Chokeya.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe you should move on.
How about a film that was good
for LGBTQ representation
in 2018?
-Well, I'm sure no one is
going to be happy to hear this,
but we at the American
Diversity Council
also found that there is no film
that more represents
the LGBTQ community than...
"Backyard Bus Bangers 6."
[ Laughter ]
-God.
-"Backyard Bus Bangers 6"
shows us that Hollywood romances
doesn't have to be
the traditional male/female
relationships we see
in most movies.
-They can also be female/female
or female/female/male.
Or female/female/female.
Or female/female/female/female.
-What about male/male
relationships?
-While there's technically
no male/male relationship
in the movie,
there is a scene -- and, uh,
I think it was an accident --
where two guys, um, touched.
[ Laughter ]
-Where can people watch
"Backyard Bus Bangers 6?"
-Well, it's currently
in wide release
to all Starwood Hotel and Resort
properties.
And I believe it premieres
on Showtime Extreme in June.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-Uh-huh.
So congratulations
to the cast and crew
of "Backyard Bus Bangers 6."
I shudder to say
that more Hollywood films
should aspire to your example.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a, you know,
a great day for representation.
-Huge win for inclusivity.
[ Laughter ]
-Out of curiosity, what was
the second-most diverse movie?
-Unfortunately, it was
"Backyard Bus Bangers 7."
-And that came out
in the same year?
-I think they were actually
filmed on the same weekend.
-Okay. Gotcha. Give it up for
the American Diversity Council!